[Music]
good lord how many of these
Halloweentown movies did they make okay
well this is Halloweentown for return to
Halloweentown June the second would have
been called return to Halloweentown yeah
I guess it doesn't matter kids that
watch these movies obviously want to see
the continuing Adventures of Marty Piper
as well as her know-it-all brother and
that third sister that still seems to
have just vanished into thin air
this film involves Marnie going to
college a college very similar to
Hogwarts almost rip offing Lisa
it looks like Hogwarts the magic spell
sound like Hogwarts a lot of the
students are looking more wizard and
witch Lee there's a few creative makeups
but for the most part people are human
looking there's even a prophecy that
says a magic student will come along to
shift power and blah blah blah you know
this kind of story
it's uncovering a mystery while still
trying to fit in trying to do the right
thing even though there's peer pressure
from the other side there's evil
students evil teachers but also good
students and good teachers and just when
you think it's all gonna follow the
predictable rulebook at the beginning of
the third act there's time-travel yeah
going back in time to see your magical
ancestor that kind of comes out of
nowhere it's definitely all over the map
but I can't say it's offending by any
means the most interesting thing in
watching these movies is comparing the
acting watching the first film compared
to the last film is really kind of
eye-opening I'm really wondering what
was going on behind the scenes or did
they get different directors or whatever
because the performance is given here as
well as in the last few films was not
the same as the first one it's also kind
of nice to see how much the family
dynamic holds up okay I can't add like
the Pipers are the most interesting
family but at the same time there's
definitely a lot of scenes that show
that they do care about each other
I like the mother checking in via
washing machine yeah it gets kind of
weirdly fun I like the cynical brothers
still trying to keep on top of things I
like the main character trying to blend
in with new friends but it's not all the
cliches you think it necessarily would
be like I said I couldn't predict time
travelling in this but yeah it's a
little hard to shake the Harry Potter
feel in all this especially with the bad
guys constantly talking about the
ancient prophecy that will grant them
the ultimate power
were and they have to cat well was it
again turned the brother into a dog and
hold him hostage so that she can get the
magical device that grants all power and
magic and give it to them but wait if
she has all power and magic couldn't she
do whatever she wants with it and yeah
that's kind of what ends up happening
and I guess that's kind of a spoiler but
if you were in the situation you'd do
the same thing so it's not really much
of a surprise there's one or two
creative things that make it stand out a
little bit but it's not that much the
best way I can describe it is the mother
who yes I know is April in the onshore a
million of you were matching that brings
up before she goes to school that with
great power comes great responsibility
the darters straight up says you stole
that from spider-man and that's kind of
the feel of the entire film you know
they're ripping off a ton of other
sources but you know they're also having
innocent fun with it and yeah like Harry
Potter the best parts of the movies are
the parts that make you feel like a real
school like they talked about this year
as the first year they're letting in
genies and mummies and yeah witch's tiny
details like that add a credibility that
make this world almost livable or at
least you want to live in it it's neat
but is it necessary or super exciting
not really but it's not really terribly
written or harmful either it's just
another Halloweentown movie that's the
best way I can put it if you can't get
enough of this series and you want to
see a fourth one this'll do you find for
me it hasn't unpleasantly status
welcomed but I can say I'm definitely
ready for Christmas
you
[Music]